all right so andy dalton has signed cam
newton is still available some people
were apoplectic about that development
but this is very very simple to
understand first andy dalton's healthy
cam newton isn't or let me be more
accurate we don't know whether he's
healthy and there's no way that team
doctors can find out whether or not he's
healthy in the midst of a pandemic
secondly there's no way in hell cam
newton has taken 3 million guaranteed
and a max of 7 million he ain't doing
that folks and finally he's not
accepting the number two job behind dak
prescott or anyone he's gonna be a
starter if and when he returns so this
one is very simple to reconcile and
understand chris cam newton is a much
better quarterback than andy dalton cam
newton has much higher earning potential
than andy dalton cam newton has a much
greater likelihood of being a number one
quarterback than andy dalton there's
just no one right now who is in a
position where they can say cam come be
our starter because of that threshold
problem we have no way of determining
that the foot is fine the shoulder is
fine the ankle is fine the player is
fine
no i mean you're right mike and this is
a subject we've talked about you know
quite often and i don't understand
people seeing it and going like
what in the hell is going on andy dalton
got signed before you know cam newton
how can that be well because in the nfl
world those two are looked at in a
different stratosphere right now and you
know yes you mentioned all you know the
correct facts as far as why uh you know
also andy dalton got signed and cam
newton being on the you know on the
sidelines still with the injury concern
and don't be able to evaluate but the
big thing is too again yeah cam newton's
a starting quarterback
cam newton unlike andy dalton would be a
threat to any starting quarterback in
football if they signed him that's the
biggest problem and that's where it's
going to be really strange i mean to sit
here right now and try to peg a team
with it for cam newton it's just like i
have no idea where he ends up at this
point i don't and it really does look
like unfortunately he's gonna have to
sit there and wait to
see if a quarterback gets hurt or
something along those lines before he
signs with the football team but you
know again mike like we've talked about
a few times over the last few weeks you
bring cam newton into your football
locker room and you go out to the
practice field and after a week of
practice i don't care who your starter
is unless it's desean watson or mahomes
or rogers or lamar jackson every other
quarterback in football the team is
going to walk off the field and go
man cam newton is good maybe he should
be our starter and teams right now are
trying to set the placemat for their
season coming up and frame their team
around their starting quarterbacks not
disrupt it and have the locker room
divided as far as who should play so i
mean i don't know mike this is crazy
that we're talking about a guy like this
and having no clue where he ends up
chris we've already seen it in
jacksonville where leonard fournette got
himself on the trade block for popping
off about wanting cam newton to sign
with the team and doug maron was on with
mike tarico a few weeks ago and marone
the coach of the jaguar said hey this is
an issue these two guys are going to
have to work out at some point because
marone understands
how it can be perceived in the locker
room when one of the players is openly
campaigning for
newton another angle to this and i
remember late in mike vick's career
it was difficult for him to find landing
spots in part because
every young player
was in awe of him now he wasn't as good
in the latter's few years of his career
as he was earlier but those guys wanted
to play with him and there was a
built-in push to get him on the field
because these guys who grew up idolizing
mike vick wanted to play with them and
you know we talk about whether or not
ben roethlisberger would accept a big
name veteran quarterback behind him he
accepted mike vick and that had to be
difficult for that year or two that vic
was there because uh yeah vic is a
superstar and cam's the same way they're
going to be guys who grew up you know
think about where we are right now think
about how old the rookies were in 2011
they were in their early teens if that
old they grew up idolizing cam newton
they're going to want to play with cam
newton and
look his best play and there was a
report this weekend from joe person to
the charlotte observer it looked like a
report and then he backed off of it i
don't know why i backed off but it's
pretty obvious
he said cam newton's not going to play
with anyone as a backup there's no way
he's going to be a backup of course
there's no way he's going to be back up
i guess it's not a report if it's
obvious he's not going to sign on to be
someone's backup what he does now
and his only choice at this point is to
wait for someone to get injured and
guys got injured last year and i
remember early in the year it felt like
the sky was falling there were so many
quarterback injuries ben rothersberger
was down in week two drew brees was down
in week two we've got a graphic with all
of the injuries look at all the games
miss cam newton himself was out in week
two nick foles got injured week one joe
flacco had a neck injury halfway through
the season matthew stafford with a
broken bone in his back there were
injuries galore now the thing is you
don't want to sign with a team if it's a
short term thing you want to wait for
that season ending cam newton ben
roethlisberger type injury that we saw
early last year and then you have to
hope that the team chris and this is the
wild card this is the wild card because
how many times did we hear next man up
when there were potential landing spots
for a certain unemployed quarterback who
shall remain nameless right lest we lest
we rile up the twitter mob but right uh
you know your teams could say
yeah okay cam's out there but he doesn't
know our offense right we've got a
number two and that's why we have a
number two and we're gonna just go with
him now it may look ridiculous to go
with the number two over cam newton but
you can't rule that out because we've
seen that time and again where teams
just say hey next man up let's put the
backup in even if the backup is a backup
for a reason
yeah well i think it'll be the right
circumstance of team that is going to
dictate a little bit whether they would
want to make a play for cam newton you
know if it's a team that
okay you know is young rebuilding they
want to see what they have as a football
team and maybe their backup quarterback
situation or maybe it's a young
quarterback who they think they have a
future for who got hurt now cam newton's
coming in they might not want to disrupt
that but you know let's say and i'm
going to knock on wood because i'm
certainly not wishing for any of this to
happen but what if philip rivers gets
hurt with the indianapolis colts
something like that you know are they
going to have the you know i'm probably
going to stay with jacobi percent that's
probably a bad example okay but i'm
saying about what my example would have
been a team
that
views itself as wow we're a team that we
think can make a playoff run this year
we're a playoff football team and if one
of those type of quarterbacks gets hurt
early in the year
they might be the teams that are more
inclined to sign a guy like cam newton
to salvage that season and again like
we've talked about so many times when he
walks in your locker room every team
thinks they're going to have a chance
because hey he's been there he's done
that and he's a special talent we know
that so you know i think that's
ultimately what it's going to come down
to listen if i was running the
jacksonville jaguars
and we get here a little farther down
the cove 19 you know light life hood
here and we want to see okay let's
finally get our hands and get a doctor
on cam newton oh he's healthy i would
seriously consider it i would you know
you you might get a steal right now in a
cam newton and getting him to a pretty
affordable starting quarterback contract
and who knows and you might get the
chance that okay he's healthy and all of
a sudden you got your starting
quarterback for the next six to eight
years so they would be one team that
jumps out to me but other than that i
don't think any other one makes sense
here any time in the in the present
future
i'm just searching uh dictionary.com for
the word life hood i've yeah
is that a star wars character is that
number four life hood it is number four
yes right
um han solo you're right
these these are all these are all very
good points though
because
at the end of the day it's got to be
something that cam newton thinks is
right and the planets may not land up
it's got to be our lineup it's got to be
right for him it's got to be right for
the team it may not happen maybe look
the guy's got over 120 million dollars
in career earnings in football he's made
some sponsorship money off the field
maybe he just takes a year off and makes
sure everyone realizes 2021 he's the top
free agent quarterback available and
he's not even going to mess with
potentially diminishing his reputation
by jumping onto a moving train in
october or november or september or
whenever and having to get up to speed
quickly maybe this is just kind of a
strange
asterisk year for him and he just takes
the year off i i don't know he seems
like a guy who wants to play gus mall's
on yeah former offensive coordinator at
auburn told mike dorico last week i've
seen that look in his eye before
um
somebody's going to get a good
quarterback and it's going to take an
injury to their current quarterback to
make it happen i think that's kind of
where we are
yeah that's a good question though mike
i mean it really is you know again yeah
what if nothing comes to fruition you
know what does cam newton do do you just
sit out the year and wait for next year
i don't think that would be the right
approach you know if i was in cam
newton's camp and i'm a huge cam newton
fan i think we both are and you know
that and
i i at some point if i felt like oh the
writing's on the wall here
we're getting a little too far into the
season
and even if you do get signed by a team
that has a starter go down and now you
have to come and be the starter it's
going to be hard for you to have success
and not know the play bug and come in in
week seven or eight at some point i
would think you know maybe you just sign
with a team and become the backup maybe
sean mcdermott does you a solid and
brings you in there and maybe if josh
allen who plays a little bit of a
reckless style of football you get to
play but nonetheless you get to practice
and get going back into the flow of
football again too i wouldn't want to
see cam
miss another year you know they didn't
get to really practice or do anything
last year and then if you went one more
year man i'm just talking from my
experience with me being out of football
for a year and a half the first time i
got back in a preseason game mike it was
like the training wheels were back on i
felt like oh my gosh i haven't i felt
like i hadn't played football and
forever it was it felt foreign to me i
did not feel comfortable out there and i
do think you have to worry about that
even when you're as talented as a cam
newton
the key though is this you better have a
pretty damn secure starting quarterback
if cam newton walks through the door
because as chris said instantly you're
going to have plenty of guys in the
locker room looking at cam newton and
saying yeah cam newton he may be better
than the guy we currently have on the
roster especially
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports